let me bring in Mike Bresnahan the
Lakers analyst for spectrum Sports Net
kind enough to join us with this news
with boogie cousins before I start Mike
Laker GM Rob polenka called boogie
cousins the x-factor for the Lakers this
season so how big a loss was this in
your opinion yeah that's the perfect
description Dan I'll tell you what he
could have gone 18 points nine rebounds
a game for the Lakers something like
that and that would have been perfect
for them they needed a big man we could
shoot outside a little bit and now that
just means more time for Joe Vail McGee
who has more of our traditional back to
the basket Duncan a bunch of lobs type
of Center so they lose some spacing on
the floor which really hurts them and
you got to feel bad for DeMarcus Cousins
I mean third big injury in the last year
and a half or so I mean he just cannot
get out of the way of bad luck it's just
been a really really sad turn of events
for one of the game's top ten players
perhaps just a couple of four years ago
and there is reaction when he goes down
it's just on it looks like a harmless
layup in a pickup game and there is
somebody who's playing in the game who
puts his hands to his head as if to say
oh my god that that they knew that this
was probably something serious when they
looked at the way he went down like
they're they're kind of holding their
head to go you know and maybe they heard
so I don't know but it doesn't look like
it would be a serious injury but with
boogie and coming back from that injury
and maybe not you know fully healthy to
be doing this now held for perhaps the
year Anthony Davis is on record is
saying he doesn't want to play the
center position why doesn't he want to
yeah I think it's more comfortable at
power forward and we obviously slightly
smaller guys of that position and
statistically he is better defensively
when he plays at the floor instead of
the five so now the Lakers definitely
have to plug in JaVale McGee at center
and they might finish with Anthony Davis
at center I would not be surprised if
that happens kind of like the small ball
lined up so to speak but definitely
losing depth is an issue for this team
that I thought they made some pretty
good saves once Kawhi Leonard chose the
Clippers over them I thought it was good
to pick up Danny Green Quinn cook can
give him some outside shooting
and DeMarcus Cousins for the relatively
inexpensive three and a half million
dollars on a one-year deal I thought
that was a nice wrap to and to see if
the its kind of dissolved before the
Lakers eyes six weeks before training
camp starts just they just a tough month
of August for sure and we know that
Anthony Davis is familiar with playing
with boogie cousins and therefore he
could let boogie play the center
position they you know they played well
when they were on the floor at the same
time with New Orleans but is there if
there any other options for this team
besides JaVale McGee at that position
yeah you know you look at the waiver
wire and you see like a Joakim Noah or a
Nene guys have not been picked up yet
and who have plenty of mileage on the
odometer - I think nope jokey no it
might be a little interesting said he
had a nice little revitalization towards
the end of his season with Memphis just
a few short months ago but as far as on
the roster no there's not a lot of big
men they really just have the two
centers in DeMarcus and JaVale now
they're down to one true center and like
you said Anthony Davis is on record
saying he does not want to play that
position so do they try to look at the
waiver wire they try to orchestrate a
trade of some sort I don't see the
ladder happening I think though they do
have one roster spot left I think maybe
do a little waiver pick up here who do
you thinks the best team in Los Angeles
that's a great question you know 24
hours ago I probably said the Lakers now
it's tough
it is definitely tougher I mean the
Clippers their guys are healthier than
the Lakers Paul George is going to miss
a little bit of time to start the season
but it might be the Clippers now because
the Marcus
really was that x-factor had he given a
double-double chance every night and we
know his defense has has gotten a little
bit worse in recent times but he's still
a great post player he can hit least 16
footer he can hit threes so without him
probably the Clippers I know at this
point how would you describe the
Clippers fan base that's a great
question I think that they're just been
experienced you know they've felt a
little bit like I the Lakers of a team
they beat us all the
there's a stretch with Shaq and Kobe
where the Lakers won the season series
they swept the season series five years
in a row they won 20 games in a row
against the Clippers so after a while
the Clippers kind of get that younger
brother feeling that are we ever going
to win anything feeling and this
franchise Dan has never been past second
round going all the way back to San
Diego and going all the way back to the
Buffalo Braves when they started about
50 years ago so there's a little bit of
I guess inexperience is probably the the
best word I can come up with but they're
probably pretty charged up these days
finish this sentence if the Clippers win
the NBA title Elway won't know what to
do laser fans entrenched in the fabric
of this city I had a championship back
to back in 2009 and 2010
Kobe people still adore Kobe they still
talk about him they still will at me on
Twitter if I say anything funny about
him we're weird about him on the air
that doesn't sit right with them so I
think there might be a little bit of a
state of confusion the Clippers winning
a championship I don't know if it's
going to happen I still think there may
be missing a piece or two but their odds
just got a little bit better certainly
in the Pacific Division with DeMarcus
Cousins going down talking to Mike
Bresnahan he covers the Lakers for
spectrum sports man do you think there's
any chance down the road that Kobe gets
involved with the Lakers I don't think
so
I was there covering the team koa times
during his last season and there was
major press conferences in almost every
city that the Lakers went to after the
game and he was asked over and over do
you want to get involved in basketball
you want to coach you want to be a GM I
don't think I don't think either of
those will happen I think eventually he
might want to own a team perhaps in
Italy where he spent so much of his
youth but I don't see him doing much
day-to-day with the Lakers his life is
pretty good right now Dan he's making
tons of money with all of his off the
court stuff including body armor and his
because oscar-winning short short
feature so I'm not too worried about
Kobe right now and I do not see him
getting involved the Lakers other than
certainly some some phone calls here and
there with this former agent Raul
did you ever think that Shaq would
develop into this marketing genius
that's a great question I've known Jack
for years he really did things the right
way in Los Angeles he loved being a
Laker you would see him in the San
Fernando Valley for breakfast and then
you'd hear that he was in Beverly Hills
for lunch and they need to see pictures
in the newspaper back the day of him
clubbing somewhere in Hollywood that
particular night and he really wrapped
his arms around the City of LA and it's
just that's his personality he but he
always has been
full bore I'm gonna party I'm gonna meet
people I'm gonna have a great time you
know what he's pretty damn smart too yes
I'm actually not surprised at all to see
the success that he has has this his NBA
career ended we had Mike Penberthy on
the former Laker player now the shooting
coach for the Lakers I don't know if you
heard this story but he's walking to
practice and he's a rookie Shaq pulls up
rolls down the window said where are you
going and he said to practice and he
said my teammates don't walk to practice
he opened up the glove compartment and
threw a wad of money at him and I said
five grand he goes no no he hit me
really hard probably 10 grand in cash
and told him to go get a car that right
there Shaquille O'Neal on a truck
actually back in the day for one of the
locker room attendants and so he could
he could kind of put the equipment and
in a pickup truck and stuff like that
for it just has that sense about him he
loves taking selfies with people I see
him down here in Manhattan Beach or
Hermosa Beach from time to time
he's on what we called strand here
that's kind of like the boardwalk right
right between these very expensive
houses and the water and Shaq will be
tooling up and down on a bicycle and he
looks like it's five sizes too small for
him and he does not care that is the as
you say the marketing genius of
Shaquille O'Neal he just had a doesn't
care and people really really respect
and adore him because of it is he who's
more beloved Kobe or Shaq Kobe and that
that's a great question Kobe was the
opposite he was the guy who was deathly
serious he's the one who wanted to
practice for at 6 a.m.
down in the Orange County in the month
of August with all the NBA is in the
Bahamas or in Vegas he's always the guy
who got up early and worked his ass off
and LA respected him for it and still
does and they feel like Shaq might have
clowned around a little too much I don't
think so I was appreciated that Shaq had
had flow with the media and he realized
he was getting paid millions upon
millions to be a player and an endorser
but but Kobe on the other hand he just
took everything so seriously and he won
and his drive really captivated the
Laker fan base here in LA and still does
to this day very much so Mike thanks for
joining us we appreciate your time we'll
check in with you during the season so
sad to hear your time in LA is there to
come back to you all right thank you
Mike Mike Bresnahan a Laker analyst for
Spectrum Sports Net you know the
brilliance of Shaq is that when he
endorses a product he buys he wants a
piece of the company you know the
general he gets a piece of that there's
a security system that he's involved in
I think he got a piece of the company
that's where you make some large cash
it's not just hey we're gonna pay you to
endorse this he wants he believes in the
product so much he wants a piece of it
and Jack's on his way to becoming a
billionaire for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV streamed for free on BR Live or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]